man muss es gar nicht auf den
karteikarten grundsätzlich gilt ja für
veranstalter habe in der vergangenheit
ja gesehen dass auch ver anschauen mit
vielen menschen sicher durchzuführen
sind das kernproblem wird sein ich
glaube das muss man einfach realistisch
einschätzen da wird mehr steuer
wahrscheinlich recht gewährt werden
erleben dass sich in den nächsten
monaten aller voraussicht nach mehr oder
weniger jeder der nicht geimpft
infizieren wird da können wir maßnahmen
ergreifen die bremsen diese entwicklung
vielleicht ein wenig aber ich glaube es
ist eine trügerische sicherheit wenn die
leute meinen weil sie nicht zum karneval
gehen oder vielleicht noch in der u bahn
der maske tragen sie davor geschützt
nicht mit corona zu infizieren der
einzige schutz wird letztendlich die
impfung seien und das was braucht jeder
davon anekdotisch erzählt hat ist ja
ganz richtig es gibt menschen die
glauben tatsächlich wenn ich jetzt den
winter noch zu hause bleibe dann ist das
im frühjahr vorbei da mag durchaus auch
das zum teil unselige gerede von einer
zero kugel strategie zu beigetragen dass
man den leuten die illusion verkaufen
wollte wenn ihr euch sechs wochen an die
maßnahmen hat dann ist das wie iris wie
durch zauberhand verschwunden und das
genau wird es nicht tun und es wird uns
immer wieder begegnen wir werden
wahrscheinlich erst ruhe im sinne einer
endemischen lager seines normalen
auftritt von corona wie in trance haben
wenn tatsächlich der großteil der
bevölkerung geimpft oder genesen ist die
30% nicht geimpften werden aus meiner
sicht relativ bald zu den genesenen
gehören wenn sie sich nicht vorher
impfen lassen